there are new details that are emerging
about the horrific moments when a gunman
opened fire
at a colorado supermarket a tragedy in
colorado
10 people are dead after a gunman opened
fire
at a grocery store in boulder on monday
witnesses are starting to tell us and
they're describing the scene as complete
chaos when the shooting started
celebrities have been sharing their
heartbroken reactions on social media
one of the first was country singer luke
bryan on monday
he wrote on twitter tragedy struck in
boulder colorado tonight
my heart goes out to the victims and
their families praying for healing
hashtag boulder strong riverdale's lily
reinhardt said
this is devastating she added it is so
terrifying to think we are all
at risk of becoming a victim to gun
violence everywhere we go
as president i'm going to use all the
resources at my disposal
to keep the american people safe on
tuesday president biden called on
congress to
immediately pass new gun reform
legislation
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives
in the future and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act
this is not it should not be a partisan
issue
this is an american issue former first
lady michelle obama echoed biden's
message on twitter writing
i just keep thinking about all the
leaders who won't take a stand to save
lives and yet line up to pass bills that
make it harder for us to vote
police say it's too soon to tell whether
victims were targeted because of their
race
but the shootings do come during a
pandemic error surge in hate crimes
against asian americans the timing of
the tragedy has made it all the more
unbelievable to many
less than a week after the atlanta area
shootings that left
eight people dead elijah wood tweeted
the horrendous shootings in atlanta and
now boulder
when is enough enough billy eichner
noted how these shootings happened amid
the country's in-progress
vaccination rollout he then put the
question to twitter
what's the point of reopening the
country if we're all going to get
massacred the alleged gunman was
arrested and taken into custody on
monday
he's been charged with 10 counts of
first-degree murder
you